[Music]  we walked over to Guy Fieri's Vegas  kitchen and started with this insane  nacho platter there was chips everywhere  cheese everywhere but who's gonna  complain about that  [Music]  and then we kind of dove into the rest  of the menu with some drinks some small  plates some burgers some fries it's safe  to say we gained about 10 pounds on this  Vegas trip but we love food  [Music]  lastly we finished off at Bugsy and  Meyer Steakhouse and I love steak so I  was so stoked to be here we had some  drinks some soup some side dishes and  then we got into the steak which was  obviously the best part that was at  least until we got to the dessert I was  already way too full to fully enjoy it  but it was delicious  [Music]